ma question à laquelle j'associe mon
collègue Bruno Miguel s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargé du petit et des
moyennes entreprises l'industrie porte
les emplois d'aujourd'hui et de demain
elle est l'un des moyens de la
transition écologique elle conditionne
la souveraineté de la France elle est
créatrice de richesse à redistribuer et
à partager les crises et les chocs
économiques provoquaient ces dernières
années par la covid-19 et par la guerre
en Ukraine ont conduit à une inexorable
démonstration celle du rôle crucial de
l'industrie pour une économie et des
impasses dans lesquels peut être plongée
un pays privé d'usine vous le mesurez
toutes et tous mes chers collègues et
lorsqu'une industrie en difficulté
risque de fermer ses portes sur vos
circonscriptions au-delà de ces constats
les transitions que nous devons réussir
trouverons dans l'industrie une
précieuse alliée c'est évidemment le cas
avec les transitions énergétiques et
climatiques c'est aussi le cas avec les
enjeux de justice sociale que nous
devons adosser à la redistribution des
richesses et au partage de la valeur par
la rémunération du travail il convient
dès lors d'amplifier d'accélérer la
dynamique de réindustr en France de la
France d'ores et déjà engagée il faut
désormais viser un projet d'industrie
bas carbone conjuguant prospérité avec
économie circulaire la France ne doit
pas se laisser distancer par les pays
d'Europe ou d'ailleurs dans le monde qui
s'engagent dans un tel virage construire
une industrie viable vivable et
équitable est un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer en oubliant aucun territoire ni
aucune entreprise de la paix au plus
grandes d'entre elles madame la ministre
pourriez-vous nous préciser comment le
prochain pro des lois projet de loi sur
l'industrie verte va permettre à la
France d'être à ce rendez-vous et
pourriez-vous également nous indiquer
comment les leviers de la simplification
de la fiscalité de la commande publique
et de la formation permettront des
retombées sociales économiques et
environnementales pour tous les Français
et surtout les territoires
je
vaux qu'à madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député bolo je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser la double absence de Bruno Le
Maire et de Roland Lescure Rolland
Lescure et notamment au Pays-Bas avec le
président de la République justement
pour y parler industrie en France comme
à l'international le gouvernement est à
la tâche pour soutenir notre industrie
et notamment l'implantation de projets
industriels dans notre pays vous le
savez hier la France ne produisait plus
aujourd'hui la France produit de nouveau
la taxation du capital avait conduit à
l'appauvrissement du pays la politique
qui est conduite depuis 2017 notamment
sur le plan fiscal la baisse des impôts
de production permet à la nation
française de redevenir enfin une nation
de production
industrielle qui se traduit d'ailleurs
dans les chiffres dans notre pays nous
créons plus d'emplois industriels que
nous n'en avions créé ces précédents
années plus de 90 000 emplois
industriels ont été recréés environ cinq
ans et le solde de création nouvelle
usines et positive ça ne sert pas les
intérêts de tout le monde puisque
certains font leur politique sur le
malheur d'un certain nombre de nos
circonscriptions mais force est de
constater que les projets industriels
reviennent dans notre pays et que les
emplois industriels se recraient on a on
doit aller plus loin c'est pourquoi
Bruno Le Maire portera avec Roland
Lescure dans les prochaines semaines à
nouveau projet de loi industrie vert qui
sera d'ailleurs présenté en Conseil des
ministres prochainement et débattus au
Parlement à l'été je ne doute pas que
vous serez force de proposition
l'objectif est simple après plus de 300
consultations notamment avec les élus du
Parlement l'objectif est de faire en
sorte qu'on arrive à un consensus et
qu'on redonne les moyens aux acteurs
économiques pour implanter des
industries vers dans notre pays en leur
facilitant la tâche en leur facilitant
la vie les technologies qui vont
s'imposer sont connues l'hydrogène les
batteries les semi-conducteurs les
panneaux photovoltaïques les pompes à
chaleur bref le dérèglement climatique
est clairement le défi de ce début de
siècle et la réindustrialisation et le
défi économique de ce début de siècle je
vous remercie